اذا هي الليله الاردنيه الكبيره قصه حب
توجت بالزواج زفاف ملكي عربي وعالمي يحضره
شغف وفرحه اردنيه لاول زفاف ملكي كبير في
البلاد منذ سنوات وتحت عنوان نفرح بالحسين
يشهد اليوم قصر زهران عقد قران ولي العهد
الاردنيه الامير
عبد الله على عروسه رجوى السيف وبعدها
سيتجه العروسان برفقه الموكب الاحمر مرورا
في عدد من شوارع عمان حيث الاحتفالات
الشعبيه ماذا يحصل بعد ذلك يصل هذا الموكب
الموكب الاحمر الى قصر الحسينيه حيث
حفل الاستقبال ومادبات العشاء الملكي التي
سيحضرها عدد من الزعماء والرؤساء
والشخصيات السياسيه والدبلوماسيه بالاضافه
الى افراد الاسره المالكه الاميره الحسين
يستعد للانتقال الى المرحله جديده في
حياته ونحن نروي لكم اليوم مع عنادى
العضايله قصه حب الحسين ورجوه من البدايه
وحتى الليله الكبيره
درب الحمار واقف صيني
لم تكن صدفه عابره بل كان حبا شغل بال ولي
العهد الاردني نظره فاعجاب وتفاصيل قصه حب
رواها الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
في المدرسه صاحبه رجوى
تعرفت على رجوى من خلالها يعني وكان في
يوم هيك اشي ذكرني فيها قررت اسال عنها
سبحان الله صار نصيب وبتلك الابتسامه ردت
عليه عروسه رجوى حكايه حب ملكيه سيودع بها
الحسين ايام العزوبيه
[موسيقى]
كلمات اختزلت اجمل المشاعر واصدقها الملك
عبد الله الثاني وبخطاب من قلب اب كان
الوطن حاضرا فيه واهم من ذلك هديه لن
ينساها ابنه الحسين
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
انعم عليك بالحسين
واليوم
كلي فخر فيه فخور
بالحسين بعزيمته بطموحه الكبير لبلده
[موسيقى]
هي الام بمشاعر تلامس القلب كلمات اختصرت
بها الملكه رانيا فرحتها بابنها وعروسها
رجوه التي تلقتها بدموع الفرح رجوى هي
احلى رجاء مني لرب العالمين لحسين
وبليله سمر اردنيه بين اصحابه وزملائه من
حمله السلاح تمنى لهم الامير الحسين ذات
الفرح انا كثير انبسطت اليوم
وعقبال كل العزابيه اللي معنا اليوم وكاي
عرس اردني بعاداته وتقاليده هي اعراس بني
هاشم فمن حن العروس الى ليله سمر اردنيه
وكما جرت العاده شباب من العائله
والاصدقاء اتموا حمام العريس
[تصفيق]
وهنا ما يعرف بالقراءه عشاء لابناء الاردن
دعا اليه ابو الحسين الملك عبد الله في
مضارب بني هاشم عين ترقب قصر زهران الذي
سيشهد عقد قران ولي العهد الامير الحسين
على الانسه رجوى وخروج الموكب الاحمر حيث
سيطل عروس البلاد وعيون اخرى ترقب هذا
الحفل الاردني وتزفه بفرح ودعاء وحب لصباح
العربيه عماد العضايله من امام قصر زهران
[موسيقى]
معنا لا مشاهدينا من عمان مراسل صباح
العربيه عماد العضايله اهلا بك يا عماد
معنا الليله الكبيره هذا اليوم وعم نشوف
هينا شوارع عمان مزينه بالاعلام الاردنيه
وفرحه عارمه احكيلنا عن الاجواء هيك بهذا
الصباح في هذا اليوم المميز
صباح الخير راويه وصباح الخير عادل طبعا
يعني بس بدي يعني اضع شعوري يوم امس وانا
اعد التقرير الذي شاهدتموه قبل قليل يعني
رايت فيه عرس اردني ولكنه بتقاليد بتقاليد
اردنيه ولكنه يعني عليه صبغه الهاشميه
الصبغه الملكيه يوم امس كان هناك يعني حفل
او القرى وكان هناك حفل وكانه حفل يشبه كل
يعني اعراس الاردنيين من شمالها الى
جنوبها كانك تحضر عرس في الكرك او بتحضر
عرس في في اربد مثلا يعني الجميع كان
مبسوطا هذا هذا الحفل وهذه الفعاليات التي
رافقت حفل الزفاف تسحر او سحرتنا ببساطتها
وبتقليدها
وبتقليداتها تقليدياتها
الملكيه ما حصل
عندي سؤال يعني يلح عليه كصحفي اليوم وانت
تشاهد كل هذه يعني حمام العريس ايضا ما
حدث للانسه
من من استقبال وحفله الحنه كصحفي كيف
تلمست شلون شفته كيف غطيته
يعني بتعرف زي ما حكيت لك عادل وكانك تحضر
عرس اردني بتقاليد اردنيه يعني احنا يعني
حضرنا الكثير من الاعراس الاردنيه خاصه في
منطقه مثلا التي يعني انا منها وهي محافظه
الكرك وكانك تحذر وكانك يعني فعاليات عرس
تقليدي من حنا العريس يعني حنا العريس انت
عارف
احد اصدقاء او اولاد عم العريس يقوم بدعوه
العريس واصدقائه الى
بيته هذه يعني هذه هذه الفعاليه بالذات ان
ابن عم العريس يقوم باخذ
الزي الذي سيرتديه العريس
ليقوم بارتدائه عنده في البيت هذا ما حصل
يوم امس مع الامير حسين حيث دعاه ابن عمه
في حمام العريس وبعدها يتم زفاف العريس
الى
القرى او المضارب التي دعا العاهل الاردني
الملك عبد الله الثاني حضرها الكثير من
الاردنيين يوم امس كان هناك رساله قويه
جدا من الملك عبد الله للامير الحسين وقال
له ان تضع مخافه الله امام عينك هذه
الرساله كانت امام الاردنيين وامام
الكمرات وامام الالاف من الذين كانوا داخل
الحضور يوم امس نعم نعم حابه اسالك ماذا
سيحصل اليوم شو ما هو البرنامج هناك موكب
احمر اشرح لنا اكثر عنه اين سيجوب
نعم اليوم اليوم
سيبدا من هنا من قصر زهران سيبدا الحفل
حفل عقد القران سيحضره اكثر من 140 شخص من
الحضور سواء كانوا من العائله المالكه او
من شخصيات سياسيه او حتى من الزعماء
والرؤساء الذين سيحضرون حفل الاستقبال
اليوم سيتم عقد القران داخل القصر ومن ثم
سيخرج الموكب الاحمر من هنا من هذه
البوابه وسيغادر هذه البوابه باتجاه قصر
الحسينيه الذي يبعد من هنا يعني عشرات
عشره كيلو متر تقريبا
سيجوب بالعاصمه عمان سيكون هناك نقاط تجمع
للمواطنين لحضور وللمشاركه بهذا الحفل
سيكون هناك مطربين في هذا الحفل سواء في
حفل استقبال او حتى في الشوارع للمشاركه
الاردنيين فيها هذا هذا يعني هذا الزفاف
كان للاردنيين مشاركه فيه بالمحافظات ليست
فقط في عمان هناك احتفالات في في الكرك
وفي كافه المحافظات الاخرى نعم نعم
جزيلا الف مبروك لكل الاردنيين يعني دائما
نبارك لهم على هذه الافراح وايضا خليني
اقول لك لون البدله حلو انا بلش يلا الف
[ضحك]
مبروكه هذه دائما خلك بهذه الابتسامه
ودائما دياركم عامره بالافراح يا رب
[موسيقى]
كل الشعب الاردني فرحان والليله والله
يتمم له يا على خير انا طبعا سعيد جدا
بهالمناسبه العزيزه على قلوبنا
بزفاف سيدي ولي العهد سمو الامير حسين
وهذا يوم وطني وفرح وسرور لجميع المواطنين
الاردنيين
[موسيقى]
يا حسين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وصلت الفقوها حواليه ظلت حواليكم الله
[تصفيق]
هذا التفاصيل جميله جدا اديش في تفاصيل
ثقافيه بتبين ببعض المواقع او بعض
المناسبات مثل الافراح لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات